what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and the Loki season finale left us with
a new Multiverse a Multiverse in which
Free Will is truly free will Loki gave
that to everybody one of the best arcs
for any character that we have seen on
screen at any point in time Loki went
from the god of Mischief the God who
wanted to rule everybody and make
everybody kneel to a literal God holding
the Multiverse together allowing it to
exist and allowing it to exist with
everybody getting absolute Free Will
quite the turnaround and quite the
sacrifice as you can see on his face at
the end there he's not exactly pleased
about what he has to do but he is happy
that he was able to save his friends
give them a chance and give everybody
else a chance billions and billions of
people but what happens next the TVA is
no longer pruning timelines the
Multiverse is real so Kang is coming and
we're going to connect everything and
tell you everything you need to know
about what comes next immediately after
Loki season 2 diving into the TVA Mobius
is future role whether or not he's going
to be in Deadpool 3 or not we're going
to break down what's going to happen in
Deadpool 3 and then of course Avengers
Secret Wars also reminder if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe and
if you subscribe and leave a comment
down below you're automatically entered
in our giveaway for a chance to win a
PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner gets
to pick one it and we pick a winner
every single month so hit that subscribe
button and leave a comment down below
now everything that happened in the Loki
finale of course is building up and
leading up to Secret Wars in fact Secret
Wars and the events that we're about to
see take place in Deadpool 3 King
Dynasty Secret Wars Etc could not happen
at all without the Loki finale happening
without Loki doing what he did Loki
created the Multiverse essentially
remember before it was just he who
remains monitoring the sacred timeline
he used the TVA to prune branches that
would come out of the Sacred timeline
and there was no Multiverse one universe
and the whole point of the season finale
was that Loki kind of had to make a
choice does he kill he who remains and
allow the Multiverse to happen which
will in turn bring about evil variants
of King the Conqueror or does he kill
Sylvie and let he who remains Live and
Let there only be one Universe with no
free will well Loki did it his own way
he let he who remains die and he went
back in time to the point where they
were trying to fix the time Loom again
this is after he who remains is already
dead and he took the place of the time
Loom saving everyone at the TVA and the
TVA itself and thus allowing the
Multiverse to exist and allowing the TVA
to monitor it now not to prune the
timelines but to monitor the timelines
for evil Kang variants which we saw them
doing at the end of the finale and they
even had a file about Kang from Quantum
Mania they said there was a he who
remains variant in a earth 616 adjacent
realm which is the Quantum realm which
is talking about the Kang we saw in
Quantum Mania and they say but they
ended up taking care of it referring to
Ant-Man taking care of the king variant
so Loki creating the Multiverse is
essentially creating the king variants
and now all the king variants have
assembled we saw this in the end of
quantum Mania also before you ask
whether or not Loki takes place before
or after Quantum Mania or any other
project just remember Loki kind of took
place outside of space and time so it's
kind of irrelevant because nothing could
happen unless Loki did what he did no
King variants are possible without the
Multiverse which Loki created so you
could say it took place before but you
could also say it kind of took place at
the same time much like we saw in Loki
season 2 episode 1 where Loki was in the
past and talking with ob in the past but
the present OB was also gaining
knowledge in the present at the same
time therefore the past and the present
or the future to Loki and Obi were
actually the same they were happening
simultaneously so you could say the same
thing could happen for Quantum Mania and
Kang in the quantum realm and the king
Council the Council of kings and all of
the other variants that we see but the
main point is is that none of that is
possible no King variants are possible
unless Loki did what he did so since he
did it the TVA is now in charge of
monitoring timelines for evil versions
of King and what is happening now is
they're going to realize that kings are
gathering actually together and are
gaining mass followers as we saw in
Quantum Mania so the TVA realizes they
have to put together a team to defeat
these Kings to save the Multiverse and
that's what we're going to see happen in
Deadpool 3 make no mistake the TVA is
going to be a big part of Deadpool 3 now
we've heard that Owen Wilson's Mobius is
actually not really going to be in the
show but here's what we know about
Deadpool 3 here's a plot summary from my
time to shine hello they State the
events of Deadpool 3 take place after
the Loki season 2 finale the TVA got
word that the kangs are gathering and a
new multiversal war is about to start so
they create an army of multiversal
Heroes mostly from dying worlds to fight
the Council of Kings Mr Paradox is
replacing Mobius Mobius was going to be
in it for a while and could still have a
cameo but they decided to just leave him
out of the story he'll be back in the
full Avengers films but Mr Paradox is
trying to recruit Wolverine Deadpool
who's a prisoner at the TVA after
messing with time hears about it and
escapes his plan is to get Wolverine to
come with him instead so they can become
BFFs so that's going to happen in
Deadpool 3 and recently The Hollywood
Reporter a couple of days ago came out
with an article and stated Deadpool 3 is
the most important project for the
studio outside of anything with Avengers
in the title and it's true because
essentially The multiversal Avengers
team is being formed in this Deadpool 3
is kind of an Avengers Assemble film
picking the multiversal heroes that are
going to be a part of the multiversal
war like Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
Deadpool Toby Maguire Spider-Man figures
crossed for that maybe some Iron Man
variants who knows and according to Alex
P who got a ton right about Loki season
2 basically all of his leaks were
accurate he States today on Twitter you
guys know what you've been saying looki
will do after season 2 bring together
The Avengers question mark see Thor
question mark help on the fight against
Kang and his variance question mark so
that but for Sylvie so it looks like
Sylvie is actually going to be in charge
of assembling this multiversal Avengers
team and will even recruit Thor
hopefully from of course our main 616
universe and first of all that's great
to hear because sylv is going to tell
Thor what Loki did and I hope that's a
really touching moment I hope Thor
realizes what his brother did and maybe
Loki could even sort of Astral project
to Thor and talk to him who knows or
maybe Loki is just kind of like the
Watcher now and has to remain impartial
and can't really interfere at all even
if it's just speaking with his brother
so with Loki creating the Multiverse
comes the variance of Kang which comes
an Avengers team that has to take on the
variants of King and of course
incursions incursions are only possible
again because of what Loki did so the
Multiverse is still at Jeopardy but it's
like what Sylvie said at least they get
a Fighting Chance that's what Loki did
for his friends and that's what Sylvie
said right when Loki disappeared he's
giving us a chance Loki never secured
the Multiverse Loki never made it to
where King variants can't appear all he
did was give people a chance to have
free will and give people a chance to
fight King instead of just one Universe
with no free will so the multiversal war
is still coming that is what is going to
happen in secret Wars we'll start to see
incursions happen big time in Deadpool 3
but in secret Wars that's when
everything falls apart and that's that
when Loki is going to come back
according to Alex Perez according to
Alex P from the cosmic circus he is
going to come back but not until the
very end I'm assuming when the
Multiverse truly falls apart which makes
sense because obviously if Loki is
holding it all together when it starts
to fall apart it would make sense that
we would see him and see what's going on
with him at the Citadel on his throne
outside of space and time so Loki set up
a lot that is going to happen in the MCU
plus not to mention anywhere else in MCU
any other project that has an incursion
that's of course because of Loki so
everything pretty much from here on out
is set up because of Loki and
fortunately for us we are indeed going
to see him again according to Alex P so
let me know your thoughts about this let
me know your thoughts on the finale and
let me know how excited you are for the
future of the MCU leave your thoughts
and comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
wolof